an diesem Vortrag den ich auf der Phil
Cologne gehalten habe geht es um das
Thema Philosophie und Computerspiel hier
sieht man schon einen Philosophen der
ganz fasziniert für einen Bildschirm
sitzt das Bild hat nicht ich gemalt
sondern das habe ich über
Dolly 2 open
malen lassen und zwar durch den Befehl
Male ein Bild von einem antiken
Philosophen der Computer spielt
warum sollten diesen Vortrag gehen und
ich möchte jetzt ein paar Fragen
aufwerfen
Philosophie und Computerspiel passt das
überhaupt zusammen gibt viele
Gegenstimmen die möchte ich jetzt mal
auch kurz berücksichtigen ein Urteil
vielleicht auch ein Vorteil lautet
computerspiele sind nur etwas für Nerds
etwas für Menschen die sich zurückziehen
im dunklen Zimmer die ganze Zeit Gamen
und kein Fuß vor die Tür setzen die das
Tageslicht scheuen die nicht wirklich an
anderen Menschen interessiert sind
weiteres Argument dagegen dass
Computerspiele mit Philosophie etwas zu
tun haben ist
Computerspiele machen süchtig besser die
Finger davon lassen
noch schlimmer vielleicht Computerspiele
machen aggressiv
und ganz geläufig
Computerspiele machen dumm das hat
einige Hirnforscher dazu geführt davon
zu sprechen dass Kinder schon eine
digitale Demenz haben weil sie zu viel
Computerspielen
stimmt das allerdings wir wollen jetzt
gleich das ganze ein bisschen kritischer
betrachten und wir wollen auch ein paar
Statistiken hinzuziehen die gegen einige
dieser Thesen hier
angehen gerade auch gegen das erste
Vorteil weil das ist definitiv falsch
meine These ist es kommt darauf an wie
man Computer spielt man kann natürlich
wie mit allen Dingen wie mit einem
Hammer wie mit Filmen mit allen Medien
und Technologien eine Weise umgehen die
dazu führt dass diese ganzen Einwände
wahr sind aber man kann auch auf eine
andere Weise Computer spielen eine Weise
die ist erlaubt philosophisch zu sein
und diese
problematischen
Befürchtungen vermeidet und darum soll
es heute in diesem Vortrag gehen es
kommt also darauf an wie man Computer
spielt
sage ich ein bisschen was zu Entwicklung
des Computerspiels das ist nämlich schon
ziemlich alt Computerspiele gibt es
circa seit den 1960er Jahren des 20
Jahrhunderts und dieses ganz klassische
Spiel hier lautet Punkt
es ist so eine Tischtennis Simulation
eine ganz rudimentäre aus dem Jahr 1972
es gab schon davor gibt es heute immer
noch verschieden Variationen einen
Tischtennis Simulation die ein Ball mit
zwei Schlägern wahlweise gegen einen
anderen Menschen oder gegen den PC da
ist schon die erste künstliche
Intelligenz enthalten die auch einen
dieser schlägersteuer überein virtuelles
oder genauer gesagt simuliertes Netz
befördert oben wird der Spielstand
angezeigt ja nach dieser sehr schlichten
war schwarz-weiß-grau Grafik kommen wir
zu einem etwas aufwendigeren Spiel was
ich seiner Zeit gespielt habe hier sieht
man aggressive Tomaten aggress gutes
Gemüse Kartoffeln mit Helmen und
Gewehren das ist das Spiel Team dreams
aus dem Jahr 1991 ein Jump and Run Spiel
was schon viel aufwendiger ist was die
Steuerung betrifft nicht mehr nur ein
Tischtennisschläger nach oben und nach
unten und ein Ball sondern geht es um
verschiedene Levels verschiedene
Bereiche um Interaktion und hüpfen
springen um auch werfen um in Bedrohung
sein um ein Level meistern zu können
also viel komplexen diese spielen hat
eine
USK-Einstufung von sechs Jahren also ab
sechs Jahren kann man das
Spielen davor ist es noch nicht
empfohlen worden warum weil es hier eben
auch ein bisschen Gewalt gibt die aber
sehr Komiker sehr kindlich
auch unrealistisch Fantasy mäßig
dargestellt ist
die Spiele Grafik hat seitdem eine
rasant Entwicklung genommen wie man an
der Unreal Engine 5 sieht die schon ganz
ganz realistische Schattenwürfe und
Lichteffekte erzeugen kann das kann man
fast nicht mehr von der Realität
unterscheiden
und neuerdings gibt es eine ganz andere
Entwicklung die nicht mehr so sehr auf
die grafische Realisierung
eingeht zum auf die Virtualisierung und
die Simulation und zwar um das Verbinden
von Avataren und wirklichen Personen im
Metaversum hier ein virtuelles
Tischtennis Spiel
wie man sich vorstellt und wie es auch
bald Zukunft sein wird jetzt möchte ich
aber einige Fakten bringen zu den
Computerspielen das haben wir schon
gesehen Computerspiele werden immer
realistischer bald können wir
Computersimulation nicht mehr von der
Realität unterscheiden
Computerspiele werden immer mehr Teil
unseres Alters
und
Computerspiele bedeutet das immer mehr
Menschen mit diesen Medien zu tun haben
ganz unabhängig vom Alter Geschlecht und
Bildungsstand und das hat dazu geführt
dass mittlerweile auch Computerspiele an
den Universitäten erforscht werden jetzt
möchte ich ein paar Statistiken bringen
also ein paar wirkliche Fakten um auch
Computerspiele etwas zu entmystifizieren
und Vorurteile und vorzubeugen das
Durchschnittsalter liegt bei fast 40
Jahren in Deutschland so als den
computerspielerinnen und Spieler im
Durchschnitt das heißt das sind viele
jüngere mit dabei aber auch einige
älteren was die genaue
altersaufschlüsselung anbelangt bringe
ich gleich auch noch eine Statistik von
Statista ja jetzt schauen wir mal wie
der Anzahl die Anzahl gewachsen ist der
computerspielenden Personen in
Deutschland und sie hat mittlerweile die
50% für die genommen 54% aller Menschen
in Deutschland spielen Computer
zählen jetzt ganz verschiedene Medien
ich komme auch noch genauer auf die
Aufschlüsselung ja der Anteil der
Computer und Videospieler der hat sich
eben mittlerweile vergrößert und er
liegt mittlerweile bei Männern wie
Frauen ebenso bei 54%, also total
ausgeglichen es ist nicht so wie das
Vorteil lautet dass Männer oder junge
Männer Jungs dass die häufiger spielen
sondern es ist genau gleich verteilt
jetzt sieht man hier meine
altersübersicht man sieht dass die 50
bis 59-Jährigen mit den 30 bis
39-Jährigen am meisten im Durchschnitt
am häufigsten
Computerspielen das ist sicherlich
überraschen man würde denken eher die
zehn bis 19-Jährigen oder sogar die 20
bis 29 Jährigen ist aber nicht der Fall
man kann sie jetzt überlegen warum
gerade die 50 bis 59 jährigen eine
Möglichkeit wäre die haben eben auch die
Entwicklung der Computerspiele in den
80ern und 90ern sehr bewusst miterlebt
als etwas Neues und wollen das seitdem
nicht mehr missen
ja jetzt kann man noch ein Blick auf den
Bildungsgrad der computerspielenden
Bevölkerung werfen und man steht fest
das Spielen hängt nicht mit dem
Bildungsabschluss zusammen
Hochschulabsolventin spielen häufiger
als
Menschen mit nur Abitur
häufiger als Menschen mit
Hauptschulabschluss ihre Reife ist ein
bisschen mehr man sieht es geht quer
durch alle Bildungsgrade hindurch was
auch wieder dafür spricht das
Computerspielen ein total breites
lebensweltliches Alltagsphänomen
geworden ist
welche Arten von Computer spielen werden
gespielt die gibt es ganz verschiedene
Casual Games Strategie und
managementaufbau spielen
social Messenger Games Fitness und
Bewegungsspiel Trump und waren Action
Spiele Shooter man sieht ähm es gibt
ganz viele am meisten die Games die
Gelegenheit Spiele die man zu unterwegs
tut
das ist sicherlich das häufigste Spiel
aber auch Simulationsspiele sind sehr
gern gesehen
wo spielen die Menschen auf welchen
Geräten welche Medien nutzen Sie sie
nutzen Smartphones vor allem das hängt
natürlich mit dem casual Gaming zusammen
das ist das leichteste Medium dem kann
man am einfachsten unkompliziertesten
spielen ansonsten hat auch der
stationäre Desktop PCs so langsam
ausgedient wie man ganz unten sieht mit
nur 36%. das war vor 10 und 20 Jahren
sicherlich noch anders da konnte man
noch nicht auf diese Reisemobil spielen
auch der Umsatz nicht der Computerspiele
sind der in Game Käufer also der
mikrotransaktion innerhalb von Spielen
hat seit dem rasant zugenommen wird sehr
viel Geld nicht mit Computer spielen
sondern in Computer spielen umgesetzt
das ist natürlich auch eine Gefahr weil
gerade jüngere Menschen ihr häufig zu
kaufen verleitet werden was auch
durchaus sucht Charakter haben kann
jetzt möchte ich zurückkommen zur
Hauptfrage was haben Computerspiele und
Philosophie gemeinsam meine Antwort ist
es kommt erstmal drauf an was wir unter
Computer spielen genau verstehen was ist
denn ein Computerspiele eine weitere
Frage ist es kommt darauf an wie wir
Computer spielen davon hängt ab in wie
vielen Computerspielen philosophisch
sein kann und es kommt auch darauf an
warum wir Computer spielen was die
Gründe und Motive dafür sind
jetzt möchte ich zuerst in Frage was
sagen zum ersten Thema was ist
eigentlich ein Computerspiel die Antwort
ist ganz banal ein Computerspiel ist ein
Spiel sonst würde es auch nicht Computer
spielen heißen die Frage was jetzt ein
Spiel ist ist deutlich schwerer zu
beantworten da haben sich die
Denkerinnen und Denker wie Philosophen
und Philosophen die Köpfe zerbrochen und
tun das heutzutage noch ein sehr
treffendes Zitat stammt von Friedrich
Schiller der Mensch spielt nur wo er in
voller Bedeutung des Wortes Mensch ist
und er ist nur da ganz Menschen wo er
spielt natürlich hat Friedrich Schiller
zu seiner Zeit im 18 Jahrhundert im 19
Jahrhundert noch nicht Computerspielen
können und sicherlich auch nicht das
Computerspiel im Sinn gehabt man kann
sich fragen welche Art von Spiel stand
die mir vor Augen war es das
Theaterspiel was das Kartenspiel was das
Gesellschaftsspiel ich denke alle Arten
von Spieler haben etwas gemeinsam indem
sie mit der menschlichen Freiheit zu tun
haben wenn Rolle spielen sind wir frei
da haben wir einen anderen
Wirklichkeitsbezug weil wir im Spiel die
Wirklichkeit simulieren
nachahmen aber zugleich uns auch von der
Wirklichkeit entfernen wir fingieren sie
und das bedeutet wir spielen mit der
Wirklichkeit wir spielen aber nicht nur
mit der Wirklichkeit was auch immer
jetzt die Wirklichkeit ist sondern wir
spielen auch mit uns indem wir zum
Beispiel andere Rollen einnehmen und
gerade im Computerspiel können wir durch
die Wahl von Avataren durch
Rollenspielen dieses
Rollenverhältnis dieses selbstverhältnis
durch ein Spiel und Rollenverhältnis
sehr gut
exemplifizieren und Ausprobieren hatte
natürlich anders Rollenspiel das
Theaterspiel gedacht das geht jetzt aber
mittlerweile eben auch sehr sehr einfach
am Computer der brauchen wir kein
Theater und wir brauchen keine Bühne
wie können wir Computer spielen es gibt
jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten ich möchte hier
für eine Form besonders argumentieren
und plädieren und eine andere Form
problematisieren die erste Möglichkeit
die ich für selbst etwas problematische
achte ist die dass das Computerspiel mit
uns spielt wir werden nämlich dann
abhängig und aggressiv süchtig was auch
immer das ist keine gute Möglichkeit mit
Computerspielen zu spielen dass wir
sagen das Heft aus der Hand geben und
selbst Objekte das Computerspiels werden
science auch finanzielle Objekte dass
wir ausgenutzt ausgenommen werden das
unsere privaten Daten abgegriffen werden
oder und diese Form möchte ich jetzt
besonders hervorheben wir spielen mit
dem Computer diesmal aber im vollen
Sinne des Wortes spielen wie ich ihn
gerade beschrieben habe das bedeutet wir
sind darin frei und kreativ und nicht
abhängig und aggressiv also alle
Vorteile die wir zu Beginn gehört haben
die treffen nur zu auf die erste Weise
des Spielens nicht auf die zweite und
auf die zweite kommt es mir jetzt gleich
genauer noch an die Frage stellt sich
also wie sollten wir nicht Computer
spielen
wir flüchten uns in eine Ersatzwelt weil
wir mit dem Alltag nicht zurechtkommen
eine Scheinwelt in der alles scheinbar
okay ist das Computerspiel spielt mit
uns und macht uns süchtig das
Computerspiel hat es auf unser Geld
abgesehen nicht nur das wir es kaufen
sondern dass wir es auch weiterhin
finanziell unterstützen durch
Abonnements durch ingame Käufe und so
weiter und so fort das Computerspiel hat
es auf unsere privaten abgesehen es
möchte uns zum Daten Objekt machen mit
unseren Daten spielen und uns finanziell
ausnutzen
das Computerspiel mit den meisten Raum
in unserem Leben ein wir haben nicht
mehr Zeit für andere Menschen andere
Aktivitäten
und das Computerspiel macht uns
aggressiv auch diese Möglichkeit besteht
wenn wir zu sehr uns in dieses Spiel
hinein begeben und von ihm gefangen
genommen werden und manipuliert werden
das sind alles Formen die man besser
nicht betreiben wenn man Computer spielt
anders gefragt jetzt wie sollten wir
Computer spielen
eine Möglichkeit besteht darin ein
geeignetes Spiel auszuwählen was
natürlich zur jeweiligen Altersgruppe
passt und wenn man richtig
computerspielt dann lassen uns die
computerspielraum für Fantasien sie
lassen uns
Rollenspielen die wir frei wählen sie
lassen uns mit uns selbst spielen und
sie lassen uns auch mit anderen Menschen
spielen also ein soziales Moment kommt
hier ins Spiel
wie dürfen wir Computer spielen
natürlich hat der Gesetzgeber hier auch
gewisse Regeln erlassen die Frage hängt
davon ab was wir im Computerspiel tun
können und was das Computerspiel kann
es gibt hier verschiedene
alterseinstufen von der USK das ist die
Unterhaltungssoftware Selbstkontrolle
dann mache ich oben rechts und
interessantes Video rein wo die USK
selbst über ihre Anliegen Auskunft gibt
ich gehe jetzt in folgenden bisschen auf
die verschiedenen Kriterien für die
Altersfreigabe ein nachdem die USK
Spiele einstuft ein Kriterium sind
Gewaltdarstellungen wird hier viel
Brutalität gezeigt geht es nur um die
Brutalität nichts anders das
Suchtpotenzial macht mich das Spiel
abhängig spielt das Spiel mit mir das
Glücksspiel ist auch noch eine ganz
wichtige Sache werde ich verleitet
Glücksspiele zu machen Geld einzusetzen
einem
Zufallsgenerator mich auszusetzen
Handlungsdruck ist noch ein wichtiges
Thema Realismus setzt mich das Spiel
unter Druck ist es zu realistisch kann
ich es nicht mehr von der Wirklichkeit
unterscheiden macht es mir Angst und
bedroht es mich oder diskriminiert es
sogar besondere Menschen das sind alles
Faktoren die in die Beurteilung mit
eingehen jetzt kann man sich fragen wird
die Persönlichkeitsentwicklung der
Kinder und Jugendlichen durch das
jeweilige Computerspiel gefährdet werden
Kinder und Jugendliche durch das
Computerspiel überfordert ist es
altersgemäß und spricht ist der
Persönlichkeitsentwicklung der
Jugendlichen und Kinder wie dürfen wir
Computer spielen ab 0 Jahren sind
freigegeben Spiele ohne
Altersbeschränkung familienfreundliche
Spiele geschicklichkeits- und
Gesellschaftsspiele Sportspiele
Denkspiele Abenteuerspiele die sind
durchaus schwierig aber inhaltlich
unbedingt
dann gibt es die Freigabe ab sechs
Jahren die sind immer
schwieriger hier entsteht auch ein
kurzer Handlungsdruck kurze
Spannungsmomente aber wir setzen das
Kind nicht übermäßig unter Druck und die
Kinder lernen immer mehr zwischen der
Spielwelt und der Wirklichkeit zu
unterscheiden das setzt sich fort für
Spiele ab 12 Jahren die schon
kampfbetonte sind aber nicht sonderlich
realistisch immer noch Komiker und
märchenhaft ein solches Spiel ab sechs
Jahren ist das besagte keen dreams wo
man eben teilweise Gewalt vorfindet
einen gewissen Handlungsdruck wenn
dieses Gemüse auf einen einstürmt aber
es ist sehr Komiker sehr schematisch
sehr unrealistisch dargestellt und es
hat alles ein sehr kindlichen ironischen
Anstrich so dass man das sicherlich
nicht zu ernst nehmen muss
es gibt es hier ein interessantes
Phänomen man sieht
Playstation 5
Spiel Fifa 22 wurde von der USK ab 0
Jahren freigegeben und NBA 2022 ab 12
Jahren was ist der Grund dafür
obwohl es doch beides computerspiele
sind die dasselbe Thema zu Gegenstand
haben Sportsimulation man sieht wenn man
genauer hinschaut dass das zweite Spiel
ab 12 Glücksspiel Momente in sich
enthielt und das hat die USK dazu
bewogen die eine deutlich höhere
Alterseinstufung zu geben diesen Spiel
ab 16 sind Spiele frei gegeben die schon
stärkere Gewaltdarstellung haben
sogenannte Shooter oder Rollenspiele
diese Gewaltdarstellung sind aber immer
durch einen Story gerannt es geht diesen
Spiel nicht nur um die Gewalt
anders fällt er sich mitspielen ab 18
hier kann der Gewalt Absatz aspektiert
deutlich im Zentrum stehen ein düstere
Atmosphäre herrscht und brutale Gewalt
explizite Darstellung sind ja an der
Tagesordnung
wie sieht jetzt die Zukunft der
Computerspieler aus Computer spielen
wird sich immer mehr in virtuellen
Realitäten abspielen sie werden von
überall als jederzeit möglich sein und
immer weniger abhängig sein von
besonderer hart werden von großen
Geräten viel flexibler und künstliche
Intelligenz wird sicherlich auch immer
mehr eine Rolle spielen das sehen wir
aber auch schon momentan
es muss man sich fragen was ist
überhaupt virtuelle Realität und Open
handiced reality von dem momentan jeder
spricht virtuelle Realität wird meistens
so verstanden dass es eine sehr
realistische Simulation ist der
entscheidende Punkt bei diesen
Verständnis ist allerdings dass diese
Simulation so intensiv ist dass wir sie
für die Realität halten wir tauchen in
diese simulierte Welt ein das nennt man
auch die Immersion das Eintauchen
virtuelle Realität erlaubt es uns Dinge
zu tun die wir so normalerweise nicht
tun können weil eben der simulative und
auch der fiktive Aspekt durch dieses
eintauchen eine viel stärkere Bedeutung
gewinnt als bei herkömmlichen spielen
wir können dadurch auch auf neue Weise
mit anderen Menschen auf der Welt
kommunizieren und spielen
Augmented Reality bedeutet erweiterte
Realität die erlaubt es uns dient
bisherige Realität physische Welt die
körperliche Welt mit der wirtinalität
verbinden und so andere Dinge hinein
beziehen Simulationen aber auch
Fiktionen Verbindung von virtueller
Realität und der physischen Realität ich
bringe ein Beispiel für Augmented
Reality hier sieht man ein Augmented
Reality Zoo wo hier plötzlich ein
simulierter Elefant
hindurchläuft obwohl er da gar nicht
physisch ist das kann man auch noch mit
einer kleinen Insel zeigen wo eine
Schildkröte an Land kommt und ein halb
seine Runden zieht und bei der nächsten
Runde versucht die Schildkröte zu
schnappen was ihm aber zum Glück nicht
gelingt man sieht das hat durchaus
realistischen Charakter das wird einfach
nahtlos in die physische Welt integriert
diese Simulation seiner Augmented
Reality das kann man natürlich auch noch
einen anderen Dingen nutzen nicht nur im
Sinne eines Zoos für Arbeitsabläufen so
sieht eine virtuelle realitätsbrille aus
die uns dann auf unserem Tisch auf dem
sich nichts befand plötzlich eine Spiele
Simulation erzeugen lässt wo die
Spielfiguren
nicht nur die umstehen sondern selbst
bewegt sind das ist natürlich dann auch
Augmented Reality wenn man die
Verbindung von Tisch und dieses
Simulation sich anschaut
wie sie die Zukunft der Computerspiele
aus ich habe schon erwähnt Metaversum
wird ein wichtiges Thema sein hier sieht
man ein Beispiel von Facebook Meta wo
wir kommunizieren und spielen links mit
einem virtuellen Roboter mit Avataren
mit Hologrammen mit Videos wir werden
ganz verschiedene Medien ineinander
überführen können integrieren können
diese Reibung verschiedene Medien wird
sich auflösen alles wird nahtlos
ineinander vernetzbar sein die
Unterscheidung zwischen Simulation und
Realität wird immer mehr
durchlässig werden sondern hochgradig
vernetzte Form des Spiels sein die aber
auch hochgradig kommunikativ sein wird
und eben gerade nichts mehr von
nordkaranter haben wird ja das war ein
kurzer Einblick in die Philosophie des
Computerspiels vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit ich bin gespannt über
mögliche Kommentare unten in der Video
Beschreibung